Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quando gli amici dei miei bambini
mi chiedono, che lavoro fai?
io rispondo: "Io faccio
gli occhietti ai robot".
Per essere precisi,
io cerco di inventare gli algoritmi
che siano la parte
del cervello di un robot,
che controlla gli occhi.
La vista è importantissima per noi:
noi esploriamo il mondo con la visione,
con la nostra capacità di percepirlo.
Pensate che il 30 percento
dei nostri neuroni
sono dedicati alla visione.
Solo il 4 percento al tatto.
Pensate anche che c'è
una parte del nostro cervello
che è espressamente dedicata
a riconoscere i visi.
E che il primo viso che un neonato impara,
una delle primissime cose
che un neonato impara,
è riconoscere il viso della mamma.
Perché dalla mamma dipende
la protezione, dipende il cibo.
E quindi, la nostra capacità di percepire
è fondamentale per capire il mondo,
ed è per questo che dobbiamo cercare
di dare queste stesse
capacità percettive ai robot,
se vogliamo che diventino veramente
parte della nostra vita,
che ci aiutino.
Però vedere è più che percepire.
Facciamo una demo.
Ho bisogno del vostro aiuto.
Alzi la mano destra
chi pensa che questa sia una tazza.
Chi pensa che sia una tazza
continui a tenere su la mano destra.
E adesso, invece,
chi pensa che questo sia un porta penne
alzi la mano sinistra.
Potete tenerle alzate tutte e due.
Vi siete arresi tutti.
(Risate)
Che cos'è che ho fatto?
Che è successo qui?
Quando io vi ho fatto vedere
questo oggetto,
voi lo avete riconosciuto come una tazza
perché tante, tante, tante volte
voi avete bevuto un caffè, un tè,
o qualsiasi sia il vostro
liquido caldo preferito
da un oggetto come questo.
Liquido caldo, perché io
sto tenendo questo oggetto dal manico,
perché le tazze hanno il manico.
Perché le vogliamo usare,
sono dei contenitori che vogliamo usare
per mettere del liquido caldo dentro.
Allora la mano deve stare distante,
perché non mi voglio scottare.
Però è un contenitore.
E qualche volta, sicuramente,
l'avete visto usare, o lo avete usato,
come un portapenne.
Perché è un contenitore,
posso metterci dentro le cose.
Posso metterci anche l'acqua.
Posso metterci anche
una piantina, perché no.
Allora, che cosa sto dicendo qui?
Che la percezione di questo
oggetto non mi dice tutto
rispetto a quella che è
l'essenza di questo oggetto.
Noi capiamo quello che vediamo
non solo sulla base
di quello che percepiamo,
ma lo capiamo anche
sulla base di altre modalità.
Di quello che facciamo,
con questo oggetto.
E allora nel nostro cervello
cosa è successo,
quando io vi ho mostrato questa tazza?
È successo che noi abbiamo dei modelli,
che si possono definire meta-modali,
formati da tante modalità,
a cui la percezione
è quello che ci fa fare click,
è dove ci agganciamo.
Però poi ci sono
tutte queste altre informazioni
che dipendono molto da tutto quello
che noi possiamo fare con questi oggetti.
Da tutte le azioni che abbiamo
compiuto con questi oggetti,
ed è così che l'immagazziniamo
nella nostra memoria.
È così che si capisce quello che si vede.
Ed è questo il tipo
di rappresentazioni meta-modali
di cui abbiamo bisogno
per far capire il mondo ai robot,
per farli vedere come vediamo noi.
E però non basta ancora.
Dobbiamo fare un passo in più,
dobbiamo andare oltre.
Vi racconto una storia.
Questa è una foto
dal mio album di famiglia
di una Pasqua di tanti, tanti anni fa.
Io sono la bambina che sta guardando
con un amore sconfinato l'uovo di Pasqua,
perché io -
La cioccolata mi piaceva,
mi piace - è così.
Però ero anche una bambina disciplinata,
quindi ho aspettato
fino alla fine del pranzo
per spazzolare l'uovo.
E poi non è finita lì.
Perché oltre a essere molto golosa,
io sono anche sempre stata molto vanitosa.
Mi piacevano, mi piacciono i vestiti.
E questa carta era bellissima!
Tutta luccicante, colorata.
E così, dopo aver mangiato l'uovo,
ho preso questa carta,
me la sono paludata intorno
e mi sono presentata così in salotto.
Io non avevo mai visto nessuno usare
la carta di un uovo di Pasqua così.
Nessuno mi aveva mai detto
che con la carta di un uovo di Pasqua
potevi farti un vestito.
Però avevo visto tanti tessuti.
Avevo capito, avevo visto
che con i tessuti si fanno i vestiti.
Avevo visto la mamma al mare con il pareo,
che assomiglia molto a questo oggetto,
prenderlo e farsi un vestito.
E ho riconosciuto che questa
bellissima carta colorata
aveva queste stesse proprietà
di flessibilità.
E quindi che cosa ho fatto io?
Io ho immaginato
che con la carta di un uovo di Pasqua
si potesse fare anche quello
che si può fare con un pareo.
E l'ho fatto, e mi sono vestita.
Questo è il punto, questo è l'essenziale.
Oltre ad essere capace di capire il mondo
con rappresentazioni che vanno
al di là di come lo percepiamo,
con rappresentazioni meta-modali,
noi siamo capaci di immaginare,
noi siamo capaci di andare oltre.
Quando vediamo qualcosa,
noi siamo capaci non solo
di pensare a quello che è,
di capire e di comprendere quello che è,
ma anche di immaginare
quello che potrebbe essere.
Questo è uno dei grandi trionfi
dell'intelligenza umana,
ed è oggi uno degli enormi limiti
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Io sono sicura che voi avete sentito
notizie di robot che fanno concerti.
Questi robot eseguono
perfettamente, esattamente,
le azioni, i gesti
che gli sono stati insegnati
dal loro maestro.
Se questo maestro
è un grandissimo artista,
il concerto sarà meraviglioso.
Ma sarà esattamente, esattamente,
quella singola e unica interpretazione.
Confrontate questo con quello
che sono capaci di fare gli esseri umani.
Pensate ad un'orchestra jazz
di musicisti che si incontrano,
che suonano insieme per la prima volta
e che mettono il loro talento insieme
e creano al momento, improvvisando,
una musica meravigliosa,
mai sentita prima.
Questa capacità di immaginare,
questa capacità di andare oltre.
Questa è una delle grandi sfide
che l'intelligenza artificiale,
che la ricerca in questo campo
oggi cerca di affrontare.
Non è facile: dobbiamo passare
da un mondo analogico
ad un mondo digitale.
Quando io lavoro sulle immagini,
le immagini sono fatte di pixel,
quindi tutto è discreto.
E quello che dobbiamo fare
è scrivere programmi,
è scrivere algoritmi
che riescano a catturare, almeno in parte,
quello che io vi ho raccontato.
Per farlo abbiamo uno strumento,
da un paio di anni -
da cinque anni, per la precisione:
il Deep Learning.
Sono degli algoritmi
che cercano di simulare
il comportamento del cervello umano.
Si implementano delle funzioni
che assomigliano ai neuroni,
che assomigliano alle sinapsi,
i collegamenti tra i neuroni.
E questi algoritmi vengono chiamati
algoritmi a grande capacità,
perché sono algoritmi in grado di gestire
milioni e milioni di dati.
Nel mio caso, di immagini.
Queste immagini sono il "cibo",
se volete sono la "benzina"
che mettiamo dentro questi algoritmi,
che riescono- sono una specie
di spremi-dati.
Li mettiamo dentro,
e riescono a distinguere
il rumore dal segnale.
Quello che è un dettaglio
da quello che è essenziale.
E siccome nel web ci sono
tantissime, tantissime immagini,
ci sono tantissimi dati,
per cercare di costruire
rappresentazioni meta-modali,
soprattutto nel caso in cui
non abbiamo esempi concreti,
nel mio gruppo di ricerca
io e i miei vandali ci siamo detti:
"Ma perché non proviamo
a insegnare ai robot?
Insegnare ad imparare dal web?".
In fondo, quando noi
non conosciamo qualche cosa,
che facciamo adesso?
Fuori il cellulare, e cerchiamo sul web.
Perché non anche per i robot?
Questo è un esempio
di quello che noi facciamo.
Qui vedete il braccio robotico.
Abbiamo chiesto a questo robot
di sparecchiare un tavolo
dopo che avevamo fatto colazione.
Nella memoria dei robot
c'erano vari oggetti,
c'era la tazza, c'era la banana.
Ma non c'era il vasetto di miele.
E quindi il robot ha percepito
che ci fosse qualche cosa sul tavolo,
ma non era in grado di dire cosa fosse.
E quindi, è andato a cercare sul web.
Cosa ha fatto?
Ha preso una foto,
e con questa foto ha trovato
tante altre immagini simili,
tante altre percezioni simili.
E dopo un po', ha iniziato a notare
che queste percezioni simili
che trovava sul web
erano molto spesso associate
ad una parola: vasetto di miele.
E così ha imparato
il nome, di quell'oggetto.
E con il nome di quell'oggetto
ha potuto cercare
anche altre informazioni.
Ha capito che è un oggetto
che è composto di parti,
perché ha un coperchio,
e quindi, quando un robot
deve andare a prenderlo,
non è una buona idea
prenderlo dal coperchio,
perché, se non è avvitato,
mi porto via il coperchio
e il vasetto resta lì.
Ha imparato che c'è
un certo peso che si può aspettare,
quindi la forza che il braccio robotico
deve utilizzare, per tirare su il vasetto,
sarà di un certo tipo.
Ha imparato che è un oggetto rigido,
non è come il cartone del latte.
Quindi quando preme,
quando la mano si chiude,
il controllo tattile
deve essere di un certo tipo.
Eccetera, eccetera.
E vi faccio notare
che questa informazione,
che sul web troviamo
sotto forma di testo, quindi un simbolo,
noi la impariamo con le azioni,
con la nostra esperienza;
e siamo capaci di- click!
toglierla dalla nostra esperienza,
e renderla simbolica
e accessibile a tutti.
E così, dopo aver imparato
tutte queste cose,
il robot ha scoperto
che questo oggetto misterioso
è un vasetto di miele
ed è stato in grado di prenderlo
e continuare a sparecchiare la tavola.
Abbiamo costruito
una rappresentazione meta-modale
di un vasetto di miele,
a partire dal web.
E con l'immaginazione che cosa facciamo?
Con la capacità di immaginare?
Quello che noi ci siamo immaginato è -
perché non facciamo venire al robot
delle allucinazioni?
In maniera legale, eh. Solo legale.
Questa che vedete qui
è una mela allucinata.
Abbiamo preso delle foto di mele, dal web,
e abbiamo insegnato al robot
a immaginare come sarebbe stata
questa mela in tre dimensioni,
perché l'informazione che trovo sul web
sono immagini, sono a due dimensioni;
ma io ho bisogno di capire
la profondità, la forma, dell'oggetto.
E quindi, a partire da questa immagine
siamo riusciti ad allucinare la forma.
Questo è un piccolo risultato,
però in realtà per noi
è un passo molto importante.
Fatemi fare un altro esempio.
Io ora vedo - quello che riesco,
con queste luci,
vedo tutti i vostri visi.
Io non vedo il dietro delle vostre teste,
però ho visto molte,
molte volte delle persone
e quindi sto assumendo
che il dietro della nostra
testa sia sferico.
Magari laggiù, dove non vedo,
c'è un alieno di Guerre Stellari
con una bellissima testa a ricciolo,
e quindi lì sto sbagliando.
Però, se siamo tutti esseri umani qui,
la testa è rotonda.
Questo noi lo facciamo continuamente.
Quando noi percepiamo
in maniera incompleta,
per proseguire in qualsiasi sia
l'obiettivo che dobbiamo avere,
per avere un modello del mondo,
noi completiamo con quello
che è più probabile.
Ma questa capacità di completare
è capacità di immaginare,
perché di solito
io vado con il più probabile.
Ma chi disegna,
inventa i personaggi di Guerre Stellari,
cerca l'improbabile.
E allora, se noi qui abbiamo trovato
la strada per avere una mela probabile,
forse in futuro, da qui,
noi troveremo anche la strada
per una mela di Guerre Stellari.
Mettendo insieme tutti questi pezzi,
siamo riusciti ad avere un R1
che impara, dal web, dei fiori.
Questi sono tutti gli oggetti
che il robot ha già
imparato a riconoscere,
e quando vedete queste barre
che si alzano e che si abbassano,
questo segnala la confidenza
che ha il robot in quello che vede.
Nell'assegnare un nome a quello che vede.
Adesso riconosce il guantone da forno.
E, vedete- a volte ha delle esitazioni.
E adesso gli mostriamo il fiore.
- [Inglese]: Che cos'è questo?
- Penso che sia un cellulare.
Mmh.. no.
- [Inglese] No, è un fiore.
Allora bisogna che impari
che cos'è un fiore.
- [Inglese] Lasciami cercare
immagini di fiori sul web!
E va a cercare immagini sul web
simili a quella che ha visto.
E ne trova tante.
Ha anche il nome "fiore",
quindi si può aiutare.
E quello che facciamo per aiutare il robot
a calare questa conoscenza in quella
che è la sua esperienza del mondo,
nel momento in cui gli serve
usare questo modello,
è che prendiamo tutti questi fiori,
li tagliamo dalla foto automaticamente,
lo facciamo online,
tutto quello che non è fiore,
e lo mettiamo in uno scenario
che è molto simile a quello
che il robot vede intorno a sé,
per aiutarlo a riconoscere i fiori
che può vedere intorno a sé.
- [Inglese]: Ok, ora un altro fiore.
Ecco il modello di fiore.
- [Inglese]: Che cos'è questo?
- Penso che sia un fiore.
E ha imparato.
Siamo ancora molto,
molto lontani dal poter dire
che possiamo riconoscere
qualsiasi oggetto,
però stiamo facendo i passettini
in questa direzione.
Quando questi passettini porteranno
ad aver percorso tutta la strada,
avremo dei robot
che alle feste di compleanno
dei nostri bambini
prenderanno le lucine
dell'albero di Natale
e cercheranno di farsi belli per la festa.
Siete tutti invitati.
Grazie.
(Applausi)